hello and welcome to this video this is
their final video in the rabbit ready to
opening of the week series on how to
play against rare opening lines yeah
we've got almost all covered b3 b4 g4g
393 and the final move to check is 1f
for the bird opening yeah the bird
opening is one of those openings named
after an animal they are not quite it's
named after Henry birth the I think
English player so it's not really named
after an animal and usually opening
lifts out the animals are pretty bad you
cannot really say that about the bird
opening it's not a particularly bad
opening it just probably not as good as
the mainstream ones black cannot refute
this but he definitely has chances to
get a decent position so what should
black doom there's one thing that I
definitely cannot recommend this is to
play e5 the so-called Frome's gambit um
some people shy away from that because
white has efore which is the funny
transposition to the Kings gambit but
here black can be happen he takes the
pawn and is okay the problem is that
white actually snatches this pawn and
the compensation after this is not
entirely clear this is interesting for
black but I feel it doesn't make much
sense to go into that as the white
player very likely is the better
informed in this in this kind of battle
yeah you don't get this often at all and
then you play around or play a line that
is sharp and probably the white player
knows much better and it is not even
that good so not a great idea to do that
um black can do many things my
recommendation is to go d5 even if you
are not one default play and have no big
experience experience in playing
the Dutch opening that makes an awful
lot of sense what now almost in all
cases plays Knight f3 and I think it's
the best move it fits into most setups
III g3 whatever NIDA 3 is played in all
of those in fact other moves have
drawbacks at least some boots have very
serious drawbacks let's start with the
move g3 trying for a reverse Leningrad
here black can play in a normal way like
g6 just play a reverse Dutch but he also
has the opportunity here to play the
move h5 very brutal and the thing is it
is just good you just stick good move in
a Texas reconstruction after Knight f3
black can play h4 just pushing forward
the thing is that after Knight takes H
form Black has two good options he 5
gives very gives very serious
compensation for a pawn yes now the
threat is rook takes h4 with checkmate
to follow so something like this and
black just develops is interesting or
you can also even more brutal intersect
the exchange and go in 5 this is an
excellent position for black early for
the exchange so something that yeah
black players should be happy to play so
many alternatives here from the solid to
the aggressive and very strong is strong
aggressive moves white sometimes plays
b3 this cannot be recommended due to
Bishop g4 we know that in the Dodge
there's d 4 F 5 Bishop g5 as a line and
here the move be 3 extra does not help
white at all in facts in some cases it's
actually weakening that diagonal um
black is playing in a way that is kind
of comparable to what we see later but
white actually has promised you to make
a move Nadia 3 we
happily take that looks really wrong for
white that structure yeah some some
e6000 on to follow this is looking very
solid when white player sometimes try is
to push the abyssion here with this and
here black has a very interesting choice
just as in the colors reversed version
with without b3 you can push e5 or can
push me three here three is the sound of
course a solid move after which black is
also completely okay like Knight f3
Bishop g6 or you can play the more
aggressiveness f5
this is some arguably very interesting
for black even though not 100% clear
that black is in fact yeah better or
anything it's just very very sharp for
example something like let's say Bishop
g2 Bishop g6 and five can check and go
for something like that it's really
check very hard to evaluate position but
black is not not in bad shape at all
however there's nothing wrong with going
ESA's a sexier if you really happen to
go into or land into this position which
is quite quite a rare thing to happen i
guess um yeah what else is there what
can go a three which probably has some
very large regions opposed to some
Knight f3 and then e3 so my
recommendation is just Knight f6 and
play Bishop g4 next just as I recommend
to play against Knight f3 it is very
likely to suppose if white is neglecting
the d4 square like this you can think
about this move it's not a bad bad
option to gain some space so the by farm
main move by white as Knight f3 and here
I have two recommendations actually one
that I don't I won't look at in much
detail
because it is not so necessary if you
play one deform and you play against the
Dutch defense with the fianchetto you
can very easily just go g6m yeah and
play a reverse Dutch there is absolutely
no point in white's extra move it's just
like it's the same opening one move
doesn't really make much of a difference
and you can attempt or I mean doesn't
make much of a difference so you can
easily just play you set up that you
play against the Dutch share tempo down
the thing is that maybe if you are not a
one default player and you experience in
that regard is somewhat limited playing
against the Dutch I think some simpler
kind of approach might be in order and
the move I suggest there is Bishop to g4
just develop the bishop down and the
idea that black has is pretty simple in
many cases he will take on a3 and try to
push e5 like Knight to d7 and e5 this is
the general idea black fights for that
if I've advanced this kind of setup was
yeah I think shown in books a couple of
times but I remember it from back in and
saying 1989 1988 yeah when a book in
German was published called sparrows
chess opening song
Kasparov known in German which presented
an overview of cos Pharaohs opening
repertoire and they somehow found I
think it was a simultaneous display game
or something like that because power of
played in this way against f4 and back
then I like the setup and have played it
ever since and in blitz chess or
whenever it it happened to to occur I
think I only got f4 one or two times at
tournaments very rarely
and this is still a very good setup I've
checked it in in the database it's it's
perfectly viable so what happens now
white usually decides to play III here
or in some cases playing them yeah d4 g3
there many moves but things that need
some special attention 95 this this move
to attack our Bishop what are we doing
yeah okay the bishop has to move again
probably to h5 you can also go to f5 of
course one important point is that we
will kick out that night with some kind
of f6 for example if something like yeah
what is y playa g3 maybe we can play 97
now or what's the wrong button I think
I'm sorry this g3 you can also just go
have sex
yeah and send him back like this and
then play knight c6 Queen d7 castles
wrong this kind of this kind of thing
it's just I mean we just play chess now
it's not a big big deal what why does
Dani is pretty eccentric yeah f4 and
moving the knight twice we shouldn't
worry about that too much what they
normally do is after Bishop g4 moves III
we should look at g3 11 and after g3
Black has a decent decent choice he can
just continue to develop with like e6 or
you can also take if you like this is
also not a bad setup at all you have to
make White's pawn structure look a
little bit awkward and now put most
pawns on light squares it's a very sound
strategic decision I think one benefit
of the setup at the should rejoice that
it makes it difficult for white to play
the reverse leningrad which is probably
the relatively best setup if
like place like g6e or c6 then I think
g3 is why it's best possible set up in
the the Leningrad Dutch the tempo up is
probably rather equal yeah I mean in
many other lines I think white is
actually in danger of being slightly
worse while the leningraders is quite
decent the tempo up so Bishop g4 they
mostly play III now and now black some
most at forward move is Knight to d7
this is the idea yeah now white in most
cases just plays Bishop e2 this is the
most common move the more testing
forever seems to be h3 let's look at
Bishop b2 first because this is what you
will encounter in most in most cases
yeah
what is some black going to do now the
ideas as I said to go for a 5 in order
to get that in we need to take on f3 and
after e5 d5 would hang so the point is
to first cover cover the d5 pawn so c6
is a good idea or Knight f6 this is both
possible let's go Knight f6 this is
probably a little bit more flexible to
be able to play like c5 in one move if
they if they intend to play d4 of course
this is something that white players
sometimes do they play a reverse so more
what we need to be aware of is that in
the Stonewall
it is usually a little bit more
comfortable for the side playing against
the stone wall if they have not fear
cannot so yeah we'll just play like e6
c5 and happy that there are all those
weaknesses on the light squares of
course it's not something where black is
like hugely better but the position is
really comfortable to play more
communists for white now to continue in
some kind of way like this like b3 this
is what they often do
playing a reversed Queen's Indian type
of thing so takes cakes five this is the
thing this is what blackest is going for
and here I think we already can conclude
that black has a decent position it very
often goes like this like takes takes
and yeah white is completing a set up
here Bishop 36 and now like we need to
Knight c3 something like that we go c6
we go Queen to e7
and yeah black has a choice if you are
very adventurous you can cancel long but
cancelling Shore deserve is a good
choice yeah and black has a very sound
good development and no problems
whatsoever
it's a simple it's a simple to play in
position um this can happen in various
shapes of form sometimes white plains f3
here when we do exactly the same thing
but white sometimes tries is to play
this before we get an e5 but I think a
position like that is fairly easy to
play when black can try to challenge the
e5 Knight quite quite quickly it just is
a simple simple to play opening like
that the most testing move is actually
the move h3 takes takes and now we face
a very important decision that pawn is
just hanging and the thing is if black
now plays Knight G to f6 looking sorry
looking very normal then white actually
has an interesting move that might
promise him some kind of initiative the
move G form this is really important to
know if white against this end we have
some some kind of tricky choices to make
I wouldn't like to play position let's
say like e 6 g5 and something like this
and that this maybe comes if
what comes it's not easy White has lots
of space so the critical thing is
probably to simply ignore the attack on
the pawn what black can't do is he can
play the movie five this is I think the
only thing to remember out of the hole
this hole opening complex with Bishop g4
that you can sacrifice this pawn if
white is not taking the pawn then we
happily play now gf6 and cover it
yeah I mean white can theoretically
speaking play something like that it's
very uncritical play it it's it's it's
possible and now we can just develop
yeah like this like c6 and so on just
normal moves so this is the criticals
yeah what now and the best move I think
is Queen h4 check there has been a
recent game 2014 it's relatively recent
when Vicki Adams with black played
Knight G to have six against
international master Thomas Randall this
is also possible black retains
compensation year after twin b7 he takes
f4 Rendell actually didn't take the pawn
he retreated to f3 this position as I
said is compensation for black but I'm
not sure that it's better than Queen h4
I think I would prefer the prefer the
move Queen edge form as they're just
nice to make sure that the White King
has an awkward position and wide of
course has no choice he has to go to the
one Jack King D 1 and now castles long a
sharp position but certainly a position
where black has all the fun and he
easily develops quickly and White's King
is yeah in danger after F takes e5 black
he goes back to e7 and will regain the
poor yeah now White has to be quite
cautious something like d4 let's say to
keep stuff after
five Queen b3 and c5 it's going to be
dangerous business if this kind of stuff
is to hit to shop for you can always
play g6 on move - there's nothing
nothing wrong with that but I think play
is interesting and definitely more fun
for black to play this position I mean I
really have my doubts of white players
love to play this but yeah okay so Queen
to e7 tween 85 King b8 this is how an
old game of crown legs run he probably
played this with white in 1990 when he
was yeah 15 years old
yeah 95 I think we can stop at this
moment black as a pawn down but he has
an excellent compensation for the pawn
so this kind of setup if we go back with
Bishop g4 97 shooting 45 is a very good
approach for black if you want something
that is not requiring
experience from the white side of the
Dutch if you like those positions that
wide usually gets with d4 g3 against the
Dutch you can easily play g6 there are
all kinds of setups here that are fine
so a matter of choice if you think this
is OK
I mean it definitely is okay but if you
feel at home in those positions just go
with g6 this is a good choice if you
want something independent that can be
played without many much specific
knowledge of this g3 or g3 bait setups
against the Dutch then Bishop g4 can be
a good a good simple choice yeah the
plan is always 97 and d5 and I think
black gets a very decent game as with
many of those offbeat systems that don't
put a pawn in the center there is also
by the way room for some creativity I
have found some pretty funny responses
against a forum then are in fact quite
playable yeah they've been a couple of P
place who went for b5 even which looks
pretty crazy I mean it is a little bit
crazy because there are really good
sound solids whatever continuations
against f4 but if you really intend to
move the b-pawn two squares forward you
can't do it against therefore it's not a
particularly bad choice as f4 well isn't
the most essential move for central play
let's say a move that is surprisingly
good really for looking completely wacky
and it's a good way I think to end the
series on offbeat first moves is to move
Knight to h6 which looks really weird
but is in fact pretty good if you for
some reason phase f4 and you want to
fight fire with fire like okay you play
something offbeat yeah I'll show you
what is offbeat
this is actually quite good the ideas to
play after you for the move d5 which is
a very nice form of the Scandinavian as
f-for is pretty useless in a
Scandinavian in fact in this kind of
situation the knight often as good
squares and E 5 is downright downright
bad yes now I mean the control over here
is it's not fits perfectly the best is
probably for white to play some Knight
f3 and now black can play like g6 and
say g3 Bishop g7 Bishop g2 yeah and at
some point here probably black should
put something in the center but if it
does like d5 we are all of a sudden in
some very valid mainline
yeah reverse dutch as g3 GG - 9 th 6 is
perfectly fine there i have to answer
the door but i've also finished with the
video i hope you enjoyed it and you hope
to hope you enjoyed the whole serious
thanks for watching guys bye bye